many desert plants get their water  through extensive root systems that  burrow deep or spread wide but one type  of moss gets its water right from the  air it's root-like structures merely  hold the plant to the ground  this plants panoply of water collecting  tricks comes courtesy of tiny features  on the hairlike projections at the end  of each leaf called ons at the smallest  scale these ons are covered with grooves  about 100 nanometers deep and 200  nanometers wide the perfect size for due  to condense within them these nano  grooves lie within larger troughs which  are a good size to snag fog droplets  from the air once enough moisture  collects in the micro grooves capillary  action pulls the droplets toward the  plant voila the plant waters itself and  on the rare occasion when rain falls any  droplets trapped between two arms are  likewise pulled toward the plant leaves